welcome to science hang out I'm siddhesh
I'm sadashiva PI from science mission so
happy new year to all science flowers so
this is our first science hang out for
the year we have today dr. Deborah salua
Austin professor from Duke University
with us so in addition to winning
several awards dr. silver and during her
graduate and undergraduate studies dr.
silver one in 2009 National Human Genome
Research Institute intramural research
award in 2010 she was white head scholar
in 2013 dr. silver one Holland tries
scholar award in neuroscience and in
2015 she was Ruth K broad foundation
faculty scholar in neuroscience in
addition she is the guest reviewer for
several journals and grant reviewer for
funding organizations she is also in the
editorial board of several journals
welcome dr. Silva thank you thank you
for having me thanks for joining science
hang out so let's talk about your
background education etc sure so I um
grew up in Massachusetts and I had a I
have an interest in science I think um
pretty early on I and I took a biology
course in high school not really i think
respond my interest in science and my my
father is an engineer my mother is an
artist so I think it kind of brought
these shared combined way of thinking
about engineering as well as um create
using creative approaches in the world
and so I pursued a degree in biology and
from Tufts University and after while i
was at tufts i had the amazing
opportunity to work in a lab for a
couple summers and that that's where I
um I really got excited about it about
science and I was exposed to research
for the very first time um I in my
senior year of college I took a
developmental biology course and I'll
never forget when I when I took this
course because within within just a few
lectures I just I fell in love with the
subject and just how um it just span
different fields and could be used to
think about I'm just fundamental
questions in biology I went on to pursue
a my PhD from Johns Hopkins School of
Medicine um with dr. Denise Montell and
i was working in cell migration i'm
using primarily drosophila for my
postdoctoral studies i decided to switch
to a another model organism using mice
um focused on um more broadly neural
development and and this is where i
became just inspired by the questions
you could ask about early development of
the brain okay so i was there for a few
years and I've been at Duke since 2010
okay and like usually like when I was
people move on in their career like they
are supported by some mentors coaches
and also do you have anybody in your
career like who helped you mentor you
host you um I would say I have been very
fortunate because I worked for several
years before I went to um graduate
school and um so I had a mentor there
Jim sellers who was kind of the first to
give me opportunities and science mm-hmm
and then my graduate mentor and my
postdoctoral launcher Denise Montel and
Bill haven or also have just been
amazing for me in terms of helping me to
learn how to run a lab mm-hmm really and
help helping me to balance both of them
have families so learning to balance how
to do outstanding science but at the
same time have have a life
raise a family um and in particular
since I think since I've started my job
looking to my graduate mentor because
she's a woman's a very successful woman
scientists and she's really given me um
kind of ideas along the way but also
just inspiration mm-hmm women scientists
can excel and have a family and also um
have fun doing science okay and I know
you had a busy person with all the
research thing going on in your lab so
just I want to learn a little bit more
about your hobbies and other interest in
addition to the research so yeah I am as
i mentioned i have i have a family I
have two kids so it doesn't leave a lot
of time for hobbies these days um in
fact most of my time is either here in
the lab or respond tongue sidelines of
soccer fields watching my kids I you
know when I do have times and the things
I love to do I love biking um wonderful
mountain biking behind my house is a
whole enormous trails in north
carolina's just this beautiful state
where you can be in the woods within two
minutes um at the beach within two hours
and then up and three hours so I really
enjoy spending my time in the outdoors
okay and let's talk about your lab black
people like grad student postdocs and
all like just tell me a little bit more
with briefly about them sure so I have
um I currently have seven permanent
members of my life Oh or our main
members i should say i have for graduate
students okay I've already graduated two
from my lab and one word will be
graduating this spring um two
postdoctoral fellows on them with me for
a couple years and then I have one um
technician who is planning to go to
medical school in the next year um
what's really nice about do because we
actually have undergraduate campus on
adjacent adequate
as well as having these guys in the lab
we have a couple under um almost always
working with us okay so um so it's a
really great mix I've been incredibly
fortunate since I've been a Duke to have
some very very talented and highly
motivated people in my lab who just
share a love of science okay yeah like
coming to motivation like in research
usually like biology research some days
you don't get Lisa some days you get
results it depend on so how do you keep
them motivated grad students and pushed
off well you know for me when I when I'm
hiring somebody or looking for someone
to jaw my love i really look to have a
sense if they are internally motivated
because um I I think it's hard for me to
UM motivate someone who gets who doesn't
have this internal drive to just learn
and be excited by and not be dismayed by
the by the little um um challenging so
of course I guess one way that I
approach this is um you think about this
as a every project as a journey and um
you may not go to the street that you
thought you were going to go to but your
eyes wide open and you do science that
is um well designed you're going to get
an answer either way that's important
and so that's how I like to balance it
and and kind of keep guys in the lab
excited about it they can see that okay
maybe even these mini preps are
important to do even these little steps
are important to do as long as we are
asking the most important questions and
doing experiments that can give us
answers yeah and how often do you
interact with them so do you have like
weekly meetings and how does it go so
yes I have um weekly meetings with
almost everybody in the lab really when
people come a little more senior we meet
more bi-weekly um
I have a fairly small lab so it works
out really nice because I'm able to UM
interact with people on a daily basis
I'm still occasionally do experiments so
i'm in lab um I love doing science I
love um I have a little bench people
sort of laugh at me but I still try to
get in there and do experiments and
that's really nice because i get to UM
keep in touch with challenges that
everybody else is facing no but in
addition to that i do have weekly
meetings with everybody and i think
that's really really important because
um um it helps me to get a sense of what
their progress is and help them along
towards their goals Oh scientific as
well as career goals okay and then of
course in addition to that we have
weekly lab meetings where we discuss
science whatever okay and like what is
the like if at all somebody is
interested in after watching this video
and interested in an opportunity in your
lab so what's the best way to contact
you I would say the best way to contact
me is to send me an email um I usually
look in that email to get a sense
ideally it has a CD in it but just I
like to have some sense it doesn't have
to be a great amount of detail but some
sense of why you have applied to my lab
and um perhaps what you're hoping to
gain from it may be a sentence or two
about your your research background so
um but email is certainly the best way
and I I am constantly looking for new
members who kind of share our vision and
enthusiasm for science I think this is
very much a team and I think carefully
when I bring people onto the team to
ensure that they're going to work well
with everybody including me okay that's
like I mean like this will give somebody
who is interested in that kind of work
brain development and all those things
like they can contact you okay and going
back to the research part like you
mentioned that you had interest in brain
development
no so let's look at your presentation so
that we get understanding on what
exactly is happening currently okay
thank you that's great thank you okay is
that up yeah okay perfect well thank you
again for the opportunity to are you
good some of our research so today I'm
going to be giving you I'm kind of some
overview and focusing in on a couple of
aspects of our work and what I thought I
would start off with is this really um
amazing movie that is depicting a neural
stem cell in a developing brain as it
undergoes divisions and you're going to
see the cell now divided and it produced
two new cells as highlighted by these
bodies yellow arrows and what the cells
are absolutely essential to our body
because they not only on can produce
more stem cells but they also give rise
to the neurons and ultimately on glial
populations of our brain and so we're
going to be talking about these cells
largely today so uh um here i'm showing
you an image depicting an early on
various stages of a developing human and
what I find absolutely amazing about
this image is as you can see we start
with very very tiny green and over the
course of development up until adulthood
this brain under those massive expansion
and my lab in particular focuses on the
structure of a brain called the cerebral
cortex now this is the structure of our
brain that's essential for higher
cognition abstract thought language etc
and we know that this our brains have
undergone massive expansion not only
over the course of development but over
the course of evolution as well and this
is depicted here with these two images
in which you can see a chimpanzee Bri
compared to a human brain and the human
brain is thought to be two to three
times as large as a chimpanzee and this
expansion has in particularly in the
cerebral cortex is thought to contribute
to what makes us uniquely human so we
know the
disruptions to development of the brain
in particular the cerebral cortex can
result in a whole host of
neurodevelopmental disorders here I'm
showing you just one of those examples
of a unaffected patient so these are MRI
images of an unaffected patient and then
a patient who has a severe microcephaly
and microcephaly of course is a is a
disorder in which brain size is severely
reduced and its associated with
intellectual disability so one of the
main goals of our lab is to understand
basic fundamental processes that are
important for both normal development
and that go awry in disease so how do we
tackle this this really challenging
question of the main approach that we
have been using is mouse models and I
wanted to show you some images to
highlight the massive expansion that are
great that the mouse brain actually
undergoes similar to what I showed you
with the human brain and here I've
highlighted with these dotted lines the
developing cerebral cortex be coming
around halfway through development of
the mouse embryo and as you can see the
structure and these images are in fact
drawn to scale this structure undergoes
a massive expansion all the way to
postnatal stages so we're able to take
advantage of mouse models to investigate
important processes of development and
there are a number of of differences
there are a number of differences
between mice and humans for example
mouse models mouse brains are smooth
whereas a human brain has has folds but
there's also a number of really really
important similarities and a number of
the same progenitors as well as same
types of neurons are are present within
the mouse brain which gives us
confidence that we can use these models
to investigate brain development and
another important point of the canadiens
here on the Left I'm showing you an
image of a human fetus from a pretty
comparable stage to on what's shown here
and what amazes me as a neuro
developmental biologist
is the remarkable similarity between
this human embryo and the mouse embryo
which again gives us confidence that we
can use these to investigate the brain
so now let me take you inside an
embryonic mouse brain you give you a
sense of what types of questions were
asking so here I'm showing you on the
top a cartoon representation of an
embryo and you can see here is the brain
this would be the eye and this would be
the year and if we were to make a
cross-section through this brain like
this this is what you would see and
these black regions here are depicting
the ventricles of our of the brain and
in green our regions which are referred
to code to as the proliferative zones or
ventricular zones and this is where
active divisions of neural stem cells
occur so let's zoom in now on this
region and what I'd like to highlight
now are these same cells that I showed
you at the very first slide these these
neural stem cells and these are
highlighted in green in which here's a
cell that's about to undergo division
and here's one that's actively dividing
so as I pointed out earlier these neural
stem cells can self-renew so they can
produce more of themselves but they can
also directly produce neurons or
indirectly produce neurons by generating
a more specialized progenitor called an
intermediate progenitor so these are
really um complex but fascinating
processes that are occurring in early
development and this is called this
process of generation of neurons is
called neurogenesis so let me just focus
on now show you an animation to give you
a better sense of how this is actually
working so at the very very early stages
of development our brains come are
composed largely of neuro epithelial
cells and these are cells that undergo
divisions to self-renew amplifying the
population and this serves the purpose
of largely expanding the progenitor pool
and beginning to expand our brains on
tangentially and this would be an
example of this type of division now as
neurogenesis proceeds these stem cells
are going to shift and increasingly are
but now these are replaced by radio Glee
opportunities
and you can see now they're shifting in
their types of divisions they undergo
rather than producing primarily
progenitors as shown here in green
they're now going to go on and produce
some neurons either directly or
indirectly and as also depicted here in
the cerebral cortex what these neurons
end up doing is forming distinct layers
of the brain and these neurons are going
to establish connections both with
within the cortex as well as with other
parts of of the brain as well and so
here's an image a negative fluorescence
image to give you a sense and what this
would look like to us when we're
studying it we can use markers shown
here in green to highlight the neural
stem cell populations and then this
region in blue would be where neurons
are located in this particular section
so one of the driving questions that
that we are fascinated by in my lab is
how our neural stem cell divisions
actually controlled that is how does the
stem cell no to undergo this type of
division the self-renewing division
versus producing a neuron and these are
really critical questions because we
know that disruption to these divisions
as I mentioned earlier can result in
various neurodevelopmental diseases so
the the questions that we're interested
in the lab is the following first we we
tackle this question of understanding
how the brain develops in humans by
thinking about evolution and using
evolution to give us a sense of what are
the differences between say a chimpanzee
brain and a human brain and can those
differences tell us something about what
makes our brains uniquely develop and
function and the second major approach
that we we use is to think about
development in particular just
fundamental genetic and cellular
regulation of neurogenesis and our
ultimate goal of this as I mentioned is
to understand better causes that could
lead to diseases such as Microsoft Lee
and what I'd like to point out is that
stem cell regulation neural stem cell
regulation seems to be a
unifying theme to all of these pieces of
the puzzle so I wanted to briefly give
you a sense of our work on the Evelyn on
evolution and in particular we have been
interested in identifying human specific
changes in our genome that is changes
that have arisen only on the human
lineage compared to a nonhuman primate
such as the chimpanzee and um last year
actually 2015 now we identified one such
human specific change in a enhancer so
this is a gene regulatory sequence that
we discovered has a role in driving on
gene expression within the developing
brain and as you can see from this image
we can use Trant mouse models to
investigate this enhancer activity shown
here in blue is activity of the specific
enhancer taken from a human as well as
the ortho ortho legis chimpanzee
sequence and what I'd like you to
appreciate is the robust act on gene
activity of the human enhancer compared
to the chimpanzee enhancer so this
suggested evolutionary differences in
this particular in these particular
sequence and in fact it's only 16
differences over 1.2 k v sequences which
is actually quite remarkable these were
sufficiently 16 differences were
sufficient to promote much higher
activity in the developing cerebral
cortex and we went on to discover that
it also was sufficient to promote more
neuron production as well as lead to a
temper ten percent larger brain size so
we continue to investigate this
particular enhancer as well as
additional enhancers that we have
discovered that have obtained these
human specific differences and here I'm
showing you a couple that were very
excited about actively pursuing so we we
are also investigating how these
enhancers function in progenitors and
shape progenitor behavior not only using
these mouse models but also taking
advantage of induced pluripotent stem
cells that we have been fortunate to
obtain from collaborators that are have
been generated from both humans and
chimpanzees fiberglass and one point I'd
like to make is that we are large in the
case of this enhancer that was in a
activating a went signaling pathway we
found that it was promoting more neurons
likely due to acceleration of neural
stem cell divisions and so this becomes
a unifying theme again modification
slight modifications to how neural stem
cells behave seems to play a role in
helping to shape unique brain
differences in humans so I'm not going
to talk too much more about the
evolution just due to time but I wanted
to share our work in that area what I'm
now instead going to focus on is to tell
you about a 2 i'm slightly more recent
studies in which we have been focused on
RNA regulation and its role during brain
development and when i began my leg I
was I was really fascinated by this
question of how do you modifications to
RNA post transcriptional regulation in
particular a player role in shaping
neural stem cell behavior and function
so I'm some of this began with a mouse
model that I had cloned when I was a
postdoctoral fellow at the NIH and this
is a mouse which contains is
heterozygous for an rna-binding protein
called magoo and here I'm showing you on
the left a whole album animal on
compared to aim ago animal you can see
that the overall body size is reduced
but what was really striking is we
discovered that with it when measuring
the different organs from these mice the
brain was disproportionately smaller in
size and so now we have a gene in hand
that seems for which haploinsufficiency
or loss of just one copy seems to have a
significant impairment to brain size
so we moved on to investigate this
further now stepping back in time and
asking what aspects of development are
impaired in these mice and what we
discovered first is that there was a
significant reduction in the progenitors
the intermediate progenitors that were
produced from these from these neural
stem cells likewise and in fact really
interestingly we observed that this was
associated with increased neurons and so
this you can see is depicted with this
thicker red area compared to a
controlled animal so we're observing
more neurons but fewer progenitors and
you might be asking yourself well if you
have more neurons why are the grains
actually smaller well it turns out that
a large fraction of these neurons that
were made we're not viable and in fact
as depicted by this cartoon and by the
staining for cleaved caspase-3 we noted
that a large fraction of these neurons
were actually undergoing cell death so
we speculated at the time that uh
defects in these radial glia these
neural stem cells are producing too many
neurons at the expense of stem cells and
doing so by affecting the ability in
large part affecting the ability of of
the new progeny to survive so we had
discovered that when we deplete cells of
this gene Mageau as well as several
other components that it associates with
it appears to actually disrupt proper
mitosis so changes how effectively these
cells divide and this is shown here with
these images in which we have a normal
mitotic spindle shown above and you can
see upon mega knock down there is a
parent mono polar spindle so this would
be indicative of a mitotic arrest so
again we thought we'll perhaps i'll just
go back perhaps Mego is is required for
mitosis and this could be underlying
some of these defects so before I move
in
you thinking about that question further
I just want to give you a little bit
better sense of what Miguel is it's part
of a complex that binds to RNA as i
mentioned called the exon junction
complex and you can see it partners up
with these other proteins are BMAA neif
43 and these are our have long been
known to associate with RNA but recent
studies have implicated them in actual
slicing events as well as um they've
been highly implicated in post on
transcriptional regulation outside of
the nucleus that is an arty localization
translation and degradation of
transcripts which have premature stop
codons so what was particularly
compelling for us is shortly on in the
years since we discovered this mutation
in human genetic studies began to
uncover both point mutations and copy
number variations within these various
exon Junction complex components and in
particular for example I'll point out
this gene rpm a day which falls within a
micro deletion duplication which is
strongly associated with with
microcephaly intellectual disability as
well as autism and so this really drove
us to continue studying this complex so
a few of the questions that we are
investigating in regards tim ago is the
following first do mitotic defects in
stem cells actually contribute to this
aberrant brain development in this
microcephaly and second we were
interested in whether Mageau functions
in conjunction with other RNA binding
proteins particular with rbma nei of 43
during brain development so I'll briefly
tell you some of the work that we've
done along both of those questions so
our first towards that first question we
hypothesized that Megillah controls cell
fate by regulating mitosis and our
predictions were the following that
mitosis defects should be evident in
these neural stem cells in vivo are in
with in vivo and second that these
mitotic defects should be associated
with
altered sulfates and the word valuable
to be telling you on this front was
carried out by two talented postdocs in
my lab ljp laws and john mcmahon so we
first set out to visualize my toesies in
these embryonic brains and the way we
wanted to do this is the following we
can cross our mutant brains are mutant
mice to a strain in which all of the DNA
is labeled with a histone binding
protein that is glows green so wherever
the DNA is we can see green then we make
thick slices so these are live tissues
and immediately began imaging them on a
spinning disk microscope so we're going
to be focusing in the next two slides on
this region here which is adjacent to
the ventricle and is where these neural
stem cells are undergoing division so
here I will show you the control and
what I hope you can appreciate is the
dynamic but also highly a remarkably
similar division time that these neural
stem cells are undergoing and in fact in
the control the divisions occur over the
span of about an out an hour in contrast
when we look at our mutant wise what we
discover and this is highlighted here
with this arrow is there is a
significant fraction at least one-third
of the neural stem cells which are
delayed in mitosis now an important
point about that is over the course of
our imaging or five-hour imaging we were
able to discover that most of these
delayed cells actually proceeded through
mitosis and gave rise to two new cells
so we wondered what are these cells that
they are actually generating and so we
turn to another approach to be able to
investigate cell fate directly and this
is an approach in which we now use the
mouse in in which new neurons were
labeled using a d/s red under control of
a neuronal promoter called DC acts so we
can isolate primary no stem cells from
mouse embryos control amuse and then we
can watch these cells as they divide
and then if they turn on red we know
that they are becoming in Iran so the
first question was can we use this assay
to recapitulate this mitotic delay and
here's the data to show you that yes
this seems to be the case we can still
see delayed mitosis in these mutants
progenitors and so this is the question
that we were interested in investigating
and in particular I'll point out in
these Magome ians we had observed both
increased differentiation as well as
increased apoptosis so here's a movie to
depict on what I've just shown you um
these neural stem cells will undergo
divisions and you can see these it gave
rise to two new red cells which would be
an example of this type of division now
interestingly in the control or large
fraction the divisions at this
particular age are progenitor producing
and this is also the case for the macomb
younes which were not delayed in mitosis
suggesting um that having am ago
mutation alone isn't sufficient to
change the sulfate however in those
Mageau mutants that had this mitotic
delay we noticed a significant shift in
the types of divisions they under web so
now they're producing more neurons at
the expense of producing new stem cells
and I don't have time to show you the
data but we also observed a similar
outcome in apoptosis so that is the
delayed cells gave rise to more epoch
taught excels at the expense of viable
cells so here's our model from ago these
neural stem cells as i pointed out
undergo early divisions to expand and
then begin producing neurons and anima
go mitotically delayed progenitor these
cells will in some instead produce
neurons at the expense of stem cells
thus depleting our stem cell cool and
they also produce cells that are not
viable so the overall result of this as
depicted by this cartoon is that you
have fewer stem cells you have fewer
neurons and then you have a smaller
brain and I don't have time to show you
the data but we you can look at the
paper importantly we discovered that
this causal
relationship was actually recapitulated
using drugs in which we could delay stem
cells and mitosis and see that this was
sufficient to drive them towards a
neuronal something so we found that the
prolonged mitosis was inducing apoptosis
under in in a p53-dependent fashion and
we are currently investigating
mechanisms by which it's leading to this
precocious differentiation and one of
the ideas that we have in mind is that
there may be damages associated with the
prolonged mitosis that are evident just
as these nails are beginning to divide
and this is an area that we're invested
so um how how does this relate back to
disease well it turns out that virtually
all of the genes that are associated
with recessive microcephaly and code
mitotic regulators and in many cases
have been shown to regulate mitosis so
we think that this could give us a new
mechanism to help explain maybe some of
these cases of microcephaly that is in
these cases perhaps what's happening is
that mutations in these jeans are not
simply just leading to no cells dividing
at all but rather they're they're
changing the overall brain size by
changing the fates via belong to my tent
so now I'm going to move on and tell you
about our work to think about how a
little bit more mechanistically how is
Mageau actually functioning this is part
of an rna-binding complex and we
hypothesize that this complex the
components in this complex work together
to control brain development because in
other context they actually are thought
to work in collaboration and the work I
will be telling you about was carried
out by a thesis student who since
graduated from my lab as well as a
postdoc in my lab both very talented and
we predicted the following that there if
these components are working together
they should show similar mutant
phenotypes microcephaly as well as
neurogenesis and we should observe
similar downstream targets
so we made conditional alleles of each
of these different components so this is
using the Cree lock system to deplete
these genes this from specific regions
at the green um and what you can see
here if you look closely is that in
particular argument a high of 43 much a
very striking microcephaly and
remarkably similar to each other and
Mageau also most microcephaly although
perhaps not as severe and one reason
that we think this may be true may be
evidence is that Mageau actually has a
second homolog in the mouse old Maccoby
whereas these two do not there may be
redundancy so mutation of these genes
leads to smaller brain and what I don't
have time to show you is that mutation
also leads to similar defects in
progenitor proliferation as well as
neuronal cell fate so we wondered what
types of changes are downstream of a
ship these beings so we turn to a
transcriptional analysis in which we
isolated his small structures of the
embryonic brain at a stage when we knew
these genes were already reduced in
their respective means as per as they
should be however there was no notable
defects in viability suggesting these
were appropriate agencies to collect
these samples and we carried out on
various types of genomics and proteomics
approaches I'll tell you about how we
followed up on one of these observations
which is the transcriptome analysis
remarkably even though these are really
critical key led to relatively few
transcriptions ranging from point four
percent two-point-nine percent of the
transcripts which are expressed in the
developing brain so we took an unbiased
by a chromatic approach to investigate
if we could learn anything about the
types of genes that were changed and
this is depicted here in which you can
see within each of these different mouse
views there was enrichment only for
three different types of proteins a
ribosome associated proteins proteasome
associated proteins and the
recently suggesting that these may be
common ways in which this complex
regulates the brain so we focused in on
one of these pathways p53 and used
validation to prove convince ourselves
that there was indeed an upregulation of
p53 in all three of these moods and then
we asked the very simple question if p53
is upregulated in each of these mutants
does this activation actually help to
explain the microcephaly so we can do
this by using Mouse genetics in which we
simply cross these different mutants
onto a p53 deficient background so here
would be a control brain here would be
am ago meat and grain you can see it's
much smaller and here is a mute Magome
Ian brain on a background of p53 so what
this suggests is that having removing
this over activation of p53 is
sufficient to largely rescue the reduced
brain size that was evident in macomb
and a partially rescues the microcephaly
evident in the other two mutants as well
you can look at this paper to learn more
about that study so altogether our work
is suggesting that this complex works
together to inhibit p53 and we actually
think that this activation of p53 may
play a role and why we have a mitotic
delay in the neural stem cells which we
believe is ultimately associated with
smaller brand spots so um we are really
excited about this because it suggests
that this complex this RNA binding
complex is is critical at very early
stages of brain development ooh help
find two gene expression as well as
splicer forms or splicing that's
occurring in in neural stem cells and
neurons and we're also very excited
because as I pointed out at the
beginning of my talk these components
are associated with intellectual
disability autism and in some cases
microcephaly and so maybe that we're
beginning to we can use some of these
findings to gain insights into causes of
these diseases so for the last part of
my talk I want to now share with you
a new more recent study that we carried
out that was published at the very end
of 2016 investigating um more cell
biological roles for RNA in neural stem
cells so I would like to point out that
these neural stem cells we've been
mostly focused on what's happening down
here in the nucleus and during cell
division but what I'd like to point out
is that they have this really elegant
beautiful long process that can extend
hundreds of micrometers in the mouse or
even thousands of micrometers in the
human brain and it forms these small
structures at the brain is shown here
called n feet now what's fascinating
about this is that this local
composition is is quite different from
other parts of the neural stem cell that
is these n feet are surrounded by inter
neurons as well as on upper layer
excitatory neurons vasculature
fiberglass and there were overall
meninges as well as the basement
membrane and we know from work from many
great labs that these structures help
our thought are possibly to help
transmit signals and a particular
signals that come from the meninges as
well as these upper layer neurons can
influence neural progenitor or
proliferation suggesting that maybe this
structure this basal process is
important for transmitting signals
during oogenesis so a few RNAs have
actually been identified to be localized
to envy and we were really struck by the
remarkable similarity between these
neural stem cells and say a growing axon
of a neuron where RNA localization and
translation is really important for for
fine tuning functions so we postulated
that perhaps there could be local
control of RNA that helps to influence
neural stem cell division and um the
work that I will be now telling you
about is a work that was carried out by
a another very talented group in my lab
ljp laws and Ashley Lennox who is a
graduate student lab who's working on
this for thesis and Jeremy Renee
is a technician in the lab so the first
question was can we to pick can we
detect rnase in these very very distal
structures of the developing brain and
of the neural stem cells so we used a
technique called on fluorescent in situ
hybridization or single molecule fish in
this case to detect individual granules
of our name and as a control we labeled
these brains with gap th and as you can
see the gap th on these tiny black
granules depict the RNA is largely
distributed throughout the brain now to
other transcripts that we noted were
highly enriched in the brain were cyclin
d2 which had been previously reported or
a Noriko suez lab to be local as to
these n foot structures as well as
nestin which had been also previously
reported in a paper several years ago to
be localized MV and we can convince
ourselves that these individual rnas are
within neural stem cells by transfecting
these neural stem cells using in utero
electroporation and so we can label
these neural stem cells in green here
and then look for RNA or red signal
within those green cells so that told us
that RNAs are indeed local oh I stand
feet and and really provide the
foundation for asking well how many's
rnase actually get to the top of the
brain so to tackle this question we
decided to adopt an approach that has
really been pioneered by Rob singers
group in which you can take a transcript
of interest introduced these stem loop
structures sequences into a reporter
transcript and then co express that with
a protein which will bind specifically
to the stem loops and is fused to gfp so
in this regard anywhere you see gfp
signal can give you indirect detection
of a given RNA and for the work i will
show you next we decided to carry this
out using this reporter that Noriko
assume his lab had discovered was
sufficient for localization of RNA to
the
so we can introduce these two reporters
into mice again using in your door
electroporation and then we generate
live brain slices and immediately begin
imaging now that one important point
about this is we used extremely high
time resolution and in fact most studies
that have there have been plenty of
studies in the cortex done of live
imaging but we used a really remarkably
high imaging this enabled us to detect
really fast events so I'm now going to
show you a movie of what one of those
RNA what's one of these neural stem
cells looks like and I hope you can see
this on the screen because it's
depicting these individual RNA grams as
they move both up as well as down and
this is highlighted here by the arrows
what I'd like to point out is that this
is the area that we're focusing in on
and in fact this is a very casa T it's
not the nucleus but it's a structure of
the neural stem cell where there seems
to be a lot of movement of rnase as well
but the important point here is that we
can we can use these movies to generate
what's called cama graphs and these
khana graphs enable us to visualize
movements over the course of time as
shown here and to orient you on the
y-axis here this would be the top of the
brain and this would be the bottom of
the brain so here would be an example of
an orang a single RNA granule that is
moving upwards towards the these end
foot structures and in contrast in our
control brains where we lack a 3 prime
utr element sufficient for localization
you can see there's no movement at all
so this was a really exciting to us and
what we will be discovered in this paper
is that the movements are actually
occurring on the order of at speeds that
are consistent with a with an active
microtubule based movement and they're
occurring at various stages of
development suggesting that this this
RNA transport within these neural stem
cells may play a role in helping to
shape the brain so we know that RNA is
now are localized at the tips of these
stem cells but the question is what are
they actually doing and so we wanted to
ask whether we could
tect proteins being produced
specifically from these localized rnase
and we devised a way which is somewhat
similar to an axon imme in which we can
remove this very top part of the brain
and keep it alive and then watch for new
translation and this is important
because and so we're going to be doing
this with photo convertible proteins
which enable us to detect de novo
protein translation so why do we have to
develop this assay otherwise we would
have proteins that are being produced
down at these structures which could
rapidly diffuse and we would never
really know if this is a local
translation event so we're going to
introduce to reporters now into these
embryonic brains again using this fancy
transfection technique called in your
door electroporation we're then going to
isolate these brains out and high then
specifically remove these M foot
preparations and they should appear as
green but upon UV conversion this photo
convertible protein Dendra will be
permanently converted to read and this
provides us a really valuable tool
because then any new green protein is we
know is de novo or new translation
events so this is what the data looks
like in a no utr control and in a 3
prime utr control you can see that prior
to conversion the dendro screen and then
following conversion we have converted
all of the screen to read in both cases
now without having this localization
element we see no recovery which
suggests that there is indeed no new
translation in contrast with this some
inclusion of this 3 prime utr I hope you
can see this on the screen we see
significant increases in recovery green
fluorescence and this tells us that this
is a de novo translation now an
important point that I don't have time
to show you but I refer you to our paper
is that these translation events can be
blocked by translational inhibitors and
we
no that these translational events seem
to the appear to be regulated that is
not all n feet show active translation
and this is an area that we're really
fascinated by to understand what are the
intrinsic and extrinsic regulations of
these neural stem cell translation so
the final piece that I want to share
with you today in regards to this story
is we wanted to understand what are some
of the RNA binding proteins that may be
important for promoting these local
translation events and we happened upon
a rna-binding protein fmr p that had
been previously been suggested to
localize them to these m feet and indeed
when we express a fusion protein for FM
RP in these neural stem cells you can
see all these single dots are presumed
FM or P granules and you can see it
becomes highly enriched in these n feet
now you may have heard about F Murphy
because mutations in FFX are which
encodes MRP um cause fragile x syndrome
which is a form of autism and we know
from work from many outstanding groups
that F Markley plays on critical roles
in is thought to play roles in neural
progenitor proliferation as well as in
neuronal migration but really it's
poorly understood how deficits and
cortical development conferred by F more
p mutation could could result in this
mutation in this disease so we decided
to use the set from RP essentially as a
tag to pull out the local transcriptome
within reason feat so this takes
advantage of an approach called RNA
emitter precipitation which has been
pioneered by by many groups including by
jack haynes group here at duke and we
were able to specifically express this
tag version in the brain and then
collect these n feet at a stage at which
these neural stem cells have not yet
produced neurons that were localized to
these tops so we're only going to be
looking now at FM RP which is in within
these n feet and we can use what's
called an RNA immunoprecipitation
approach
which essentially uses an antibody based
method to isolate all of those RNAs
associated with FM RP and then we can
use microarray analysis to detect those
RNAs that are enriched within 10 feet
and what we were really excited about
when we looked at the data was the
following so first of all we found that
there were 150 and transcripts that
showed significant enrichment both above
our negative control and above the total
input and what I hope you can appreciate
here is that when we step back and ask
what types of transcripts are encoded up
there we see that there is a strong
enrichment for proteins for transcripts
encoding cytoskeletal protein as well as
signaling proteins and chromatin
regulatory factors and what was also
interesting to us is that we noted that
there was a strong enrichment for
transcripts that are associated with
autism which would be consistent with
the idea that Mr P is associated with
rnase that may be important in during
brain development for potentially for
this disease the other observation that
we made was that Mr P some targets that
we had identified in these n feed
structures were some of the same ones
that have been observed in the adult
brain so we took one of these targets
and asked does that from RP actually
regulate it and the the way that we did
this was now using in situ hybridization
and what we found is that in an F Murphy
mutant we have see a significant
reduction in localization of this
transcript which encodes a non-canonical
motor protein kinesin um likewise we
observed that when we used our live
imaging acid we could see a significant
reduction in the speeds at which FM RP
moved this via skip 26 a reporter
constructs and so what this suggests is
that f merkley plays a role in RNA
transport within radio
and work by others such as guerra de Sol
and others have shown that Mr P actually
can influence our any transport in
postmitotic neurons so this is
consistent with that idea so I would
like to conclude this part of the talk
now and tell you where summarize where
we're at and what we're thinking about
so we're really excited by this idea
that RNAs are actively moved within
neural stem cells to reside within these
end foot structures and what this
suggests is that radial glia are in fact
a highway for molecular transport of RNA
as well as RNA binding proteins and we
think that this is really opening the
door to thinking about these these basal
structures as um as signaling structures
which could both said send molecules
from the cell body up to the top and
potentially receive signals up at the
top from the surrounding cells to then
communicate back down towards the bottom
of the brain so what on where are we
going with this in the future well we
are fascinated by this question of how
is translation regulated we we now know
that of a few transcripts that seem to
be regulated by translation but we're
what other types of transcripts are are
translated and how is this regulated the
second burning question that we have of
course is what is the function of local
translation and noriko sunnis lab who
really kind of pioneered this idea that
rnas could be important up here
suggested that it may be important for
self aid but we're also favoring the
idea given the transcriptome that we've
discovered that local remodeling events
are occurring in these n feet both as
the neural stem cells are growing over
the course of brain development but also
are helping to receive local signals
from from the meninges and other cell
types that are critical for
communicating information from the pia
down to the ventricle and you can
imagine this would be particularly
important in a human brain where the
distances can be up to as I said several
hundred or a thousand micrometers long
so um I hope today I've been able to
convince you that um by investigating
normal processes of development as well
as evolution we've gained um we've begun
to gain insights into potential causes
of neurodevelopmental diseases and one
of the themes that has emerged from our
research as well as those of many of my
colleagues in the field is that
modifications to neural stem cell
function are clearly relevant for
helping to shape our brains and I will
just finish now by faking members of my
lab who I've been extremely fortunate to
have many of whom are shown here and i
think i've pretty much highlighted
everybody on who's been working on the
lab as well as outstanding collaborators
and investigators who have shared
reagents and then of course my funding
sources thank you thanks not busy woman
ah so can you place the stop sharing
stop shelling yeah I do okay so that's
an interesting talk I had seen some of
the papers about radial glia and all
those things one of the questions I have
is like this may be related or may not
be related when you talk about the
microcephaly so there is a lot of like
Zika virus causes microcephaly yes so
I'm trying to see like is there any
connection can you build that connection
between Zika and whatever you see in the
mouse brain yes absolutely and I think
um yeah bazooka so you're pointing out
the the recent discovery is that if
virus infection prenatally is associated
with a significant incidence of smaller
brain size and they're born um and
literature from many groups is now
beginning to point to neural stem cell
defects as being a contributing factor
in Zika mediated microcephaly a number
of groups have used both males
excuse me mouse models as well as human
brain organoids show that if you infect
with Zika virus neural stem cell
divisions as well as it can lead to
defects in neural stem cell divisions as
well as overall survival of cells in the
brain and this seems to be really
associated with early infection right
now so studies are suggesting that
infections at the very early stages when
neural stem cells are perhaps undergoing
these massive expansions these
self-renewal divisions or shifting to
asymmetric divisions those seem to be a
particularly sensitive stage so I think
there are a lot of parallels to be drawn
and we actually are working on this as
well we're very interested in using some
of the tools that we've built in
investigating genetic causes of
microcephaly to invest to better
understand how Zika virus works and
we're collaborating with virologists
here at Duke to to think about this more
carefully um it's a fascinating and an
extremely fast-moving field yeah yeah
yeah so I thought like as soon as I
heard microcephaly I thought okay and
maybe you can build some connections
there yeah they're absolutely are and
there's microcephaly people are now
finding that microcephaly genes
themselves the genetic causes are
influenced by Zika virus as well yeah so
I think because of the lack of time so
we won't go further much because it's
almost like going to be 830 okay for us
and I really thank you for taking time
and your effort in bringing this your
research to our viewers and really wish
you good luck in all your research
futurist earth and we welcome you
anytime like if you think that that is
more you can say about your work please
shoot me an email and we'll have another
one whenever you are ready ok that's
great well thank you again for featuring
the work from our lab it was really a
pleasure yeah good thank you so much
thank you bye-bye